by now you've probably heard that the
wildly popular podcast serial which
focuses on one story in depth is back
for a second season this season looks at
a case that you might have already heard
a bit about that of Bowe Bergdahl to
catch you up to speed before you dive
into the podcast here's a quick
refresher on what you should know Bowe
Bergdahl is a US soldier who was serving
at a military base in Afghanistan not
far from a Taliban stronghold when he
disappeared in 2009 but the Taliban
captured him and later put out a video
of him appealing for his release in the
video Bergdahl claimed that he was
lagging behind a patrol when he was
captured six US servicemen died not long
after Bergdahl vanished some blamed the
deaths on the massive rescue operation
in search of him Bergdahl was the u.s.
is only powa at the time then the
military said Bergdahl hadn't been
captured while on patrol but that he
walked off the base voluntarily Bergdahl
was finally released in 2014 after the
u.s. negotiated in exchange for five
Taliban prisoners held at Guantanamo Bay
a deal brokered by Qatar and that deal
was very controversial the GOP claimed
that Obama violated federal law when
negotiating that exchange in fact the
House Armed Services Committee released
a report this week saying Congress
wasn't notified of the Gitmo detainee
release until two hours before it
happened not 30 days before as required
by law and many weren't happy that the
president exchanged Guantanamo prisoners
for a soldier who some called a traitor
in March of 2015 Bergdahl was charged
with desertion and misbehavior before
the enemy his lawyers requested that he
not be jailed or discharged from the
military Bergdahl is waiting on the
verdict and if convicted he could face
life in prison and throughout this whole
ordeal no one's really heard from
Bergdahl until now
season of cereal raised questions about
the flaws within the US justice system
will this new season shed light on us
conduct in Afghanistan
you